a particle is traveling in simple
harmonic motion about the origin pause
so we know what simple harmonic motion
is at the moment it's that up and down
or the missus lee is running back and
forth which you'll never forget ever
again don't worry where you're will do
it so you've got someone better looking
at least in your memory now that's
fantastic simple harmonic motion it's
about the origin now remember when we
talked about you might like to draw a
little rough small set of axes for
yourself over here I actually could you
into this just before we started this
topic of simple harmonic motion but when
you think about the sine or the cosine
waves so here's the same wave looseness
okay we can think of it as here's time
progressing along here's our
displacement right and you can see
whether this is up or down or left and
right or back and forth the center or
where it's moving around is going to be
this axis in this case right but we can
move this axis that's what we're going
to be doing a little bit later on
for now though it says we don't want you
move the axis we just want to move it
about the origin okay it is a little bit
weird because the origin we're used to
thinking of as this thing right the
intersection of the two coordinate axes
but in this context the origin the
origin is actually everywhere along this
line right because as time progresses
that's still the origin right so if I'm
like here and I asked you how far you
from the origin if this is you know the
regular sine curve you would say I am
one unit from the origin do you see that
that's a bit that's a bit weird isn't it
so let's keep that in mind and move on
it is a period of 24 seconds and an
amplitude of 120 meters so they give us
some data which we're going to use
shortly to write down the functions
right initially it is at the origin
moving forward okay so at that last
point there we have two other crucial
pieces of information that we are going
to fit into our functions which are
numerical at least I don't look in
miracle right initially it's at the
origin so coincidentally I drew a sine
curve here and that's what you would
choose if you're starting in the origin
because that's where sign begins if we
weren't beginning at the origin if we
were beginning say up here we would
choose cosine because you can use either
you could use a phase shift to get you
from here to there as we'll look at
later but you might as well use a
function that just starts there anyway
if that's what they tell you it does
they say it's moving forwards what
difference does that make if we've
established that I've got a sine curve
if for example they said they wanted it
to move backwards initially that would
be the opposite what would be the
difference in the equation that I choose
wouldn't you just want to say it again
Paul negative sign so you know to draw
this but this is what I would have right
so I've defined forwards as up on the
x-axis and backwards is down on the
x-axis okay so now excited to fit this
all together
let's now tackle this is question nine
it's not the 15th anymore let's tackle
Part A and it says write down the
functions of displacement and velocity
and then state the maximum speed okay
so we've already to begin to unpack this
statement for sorry the function for a
displacement when I say x equals we've
just established it's going to start
from the origin it's gonna start move
you forward so it's going to have a sign
in it right what other bits are going to
be important what defines how far it
goes up and down what number up and down
up and down this is going to be
amplitude right and you can see because
we use that word that language because
it's in the question the amplitude is
120 meters so where does that number go
the air per tube yeah it's going to be
this coefficient at the front here so
I'm gonna slap 120 there and in the next
piece of information which they give us
the numerical data or the previous
rather is that the period is 24 seconds
the period is 24 seconds that's worth
writing down period equals 24 seconds
now if that's the case that's also going
to fiddle with our numbers which number
before we work out what it is which
numbers are fiddling with you've already
got this one where Oscar numbers go
where else to I have breaks in here
it's it's gonna be in the brackets right
that big gaping hole that's there we
know this is a function of time but
there's going to be some coefficient
here which change changes how quickly
it's oscillating up and down okay
oh sorry back and forth right so how do
I work this out if the period is 24
seconds think back to your knowledge of
graphing right if I just for example had
a regular curve like this x equals sine
T no weird coefficients or anything like
that what would its period be how long
does sine normally take to come back to
the beginning 2 pi very good okay so in
this case what I've got is sine of 1 T
what if I had x equals sine 2t
what would the period be now it would be
halved it would be just pi seconds right
one of the ways I like to think about it
is that it all starts from 2 pi and you
get this number of copies of the graph
within 2 pi so you're going to get 2
copies within 2 pi that's why the period
is pi so you might remember now
hopefully this is jogging your memory
that the period just generally speaking
in these terms is going to be 2 pi
divided by whatever it is that
coefficient is whether it's 1 or 2 or
something else I'm about to find out
over here so 2 pi on n it is worth
having that as a fact that you can
recall about these graphs because you
don't really want to fuss around getting
this information you just want to have
it quickly okay so if 24 is that period
I mean I can say 2 pi on and equals 24
what would you like me to do now yeah I
I actually want and write this
coefficient here so I'm going to
multiply that across and then I'm going
to divide by 24 which I think once it
cancels with the two leaves me with Pi
on 12 are you okay with that so that's
what belongs up here does it feed all
the information that we've got we just
talked very explicitly about the period
and the amplitude and we crunched the
numbers on that so they should be okay
is it going to be initially at the
origin what makes Italy the origin which
piece of information did I choose
think I drew it over there right if I
didn't want to start the origin what
would I do what we've changed I'm gonna
I'm gonna wait and pause and think think
this is one of those fundamental things
that we've got here it's one of the very
first things that we wrote down in fact
what kind of function is it we can do
better than this Monday morning you
twelve it's a it's a sine function right
that's what I chose because it starts at
the origin if it weren't I might choose
cosine okay and then lastly it moves
forward and the difference would be well
there's a plus sign there yeah it's just
hidden we don't heed to write it okay
but that's what launches it off in the
positive direction to begin with okay
I've got my equation for displacement do
you reckon you could come up with the
equation for velocity what would you do
to this to get velocity you
differentiate off you go
[Applause]